Ya hemos pasado algún tiempo analizando la Ley
de los gases ideales y también hemos pensado
en escenarios en los que las cosas pueden ser
diferentes de lo que la Ley de los gases ideales
puede predecir. Lo que vamos a hacer en este
video es profundizar más en escenarios en los
que podríamos divergir un poco o quizá mucho
de la Ley de los gases ideales. Entonces tengo
tres escenarios aquí: en este primer escenario
tengo una alta temperatura y un gran volumen,
y ambos son realmente importantes porque, cuando
pensamos en que los gases se acercan al ideal,
es en esa situación en la que el volumen de las
partículas es insignificante con respecto al
volumen del contenedor, y al menos aquí parece que
ese podría ser el caso ya que tengo un volumen muy
grande. Esto no está dibujado a escala, dibujé las
partículas de este tamaño para que pudieras verlas
y la temperatura es alta. Esto nos ayuda a darnos
cuenta de que las interacciones intermoleculares
o atracciones entre las partículas quizá no sean
tan significativas, por lo tanto, en un escenario
de gran volumen y alta temperatura esto podría
estar bastante cerca de lo ideal. Ahora bien,
no será perfectamente ideal porque los gases
reales tienen cierto volumen y tienen algunas
interacciones intermoleculares. Pero ahora
cambiemos un poco las cosas, pasemos al mismo
volumen: aquí todavía estamos tratando con
un gran volumen, pero bajemos la temperatura,
la bajamos tanto que podemos ver que debido a
que la temperatura es proporcional a la energía
cinética promedio de las partículas, estas
flechas en promedio son un poco más pequeñas.
Digamos que bajamos la temperatura cerca del
punto de condensación. Recuerda: el punto de
condensación de un gas es cuando las moléculas se
atraen entre sí e incluso comienzan a agruparse.
Si imaginamos vapores de agua, aquí están
comenzando a convertirse en pequeñas gotas de
agua líquida porque se sienten muy atraídos entre
sí. Entonces, en esta situación donde acabamos
de bajar la temperatura, la Ley de los gases
ideales ya predice que si se mantiene todo lo
demás constante la presión bajará. Si despejamos
la presión, tendríamos que P = nRT / V. Entonces,
si sólo baja la temperatura, la Ley de los
gases ideales predice que su presión será menor,
pero en esta situación con un gas real, debido a
que estamos cerca de ese punto de condensación,
estos gases, estas partículas, se atraen cada vez
más entre sí, por lo tanto, es menos probable que
choquen con los lados del recipiente, o si
lo hacen lo harán con menos vigor. Entonces,
en esta situación, un gas real, debido a la
atracción intermolecular entre las partículas,
en realidad tendrá una presión más baja de
lo que puede predecir la Ley de los gases
ideales. La Ley de los gases ideales ya predice
que si baja la temperatura la presión disminuirá,
pero verás que para un gas real en este escenario
P es aún más baja. Ahora veamos otro escenario
en donde mantenemos la temperatura alta
que teníamos en el escenario original,
pero ahora tenemos un volumen pequeño. Quizá esta
parte superior del contenedor sea un pistón y lo
empujamos hacia abajo, así. Bueno, según la Ley de
los gases ideales si despejamos P nuevamente queda
que P = nRT / V, y si disminuyes el denominador
aquí aumentará el valor de toda la expresión,
por lo tanto, predice que tendrá una presión
más alta, que las partículas rebotarán en los
lados del recipiente con más frecuencia y
con más vigor. Pero si tenemos un volumen
realmente pequeño del contenedor, ya no podemos
suponer que el volumen de las partículas será
insignificante en comparación con el volumen del
contenedor, y así el volumen efectivo que tienen
las partículas para moverse es incluso más bajo
de lo que vemos en esta ecuación. Entonces estas
partículas tienen mucho menos espacio para
rebotar porque ocupan parte del espacio, por
lo que rebotarán en los lados del recipiente con
más frecuencia e incluso con más vigor. Entonces
aquí la presión para un gas real es incluso mayor
que la que predice la Ley de los gases ideales.